[Música]
usualmente contamos historias para
compartir ideas y por accidente yo lo
hice al revés hoy les voy a contar
historias
y la primera que era sorpresa tengo una
mis favoritas creo que varios la
conocemos se empieza así hace mucho
tiempo tengo una galaxia muy muy lejana
nació un niño
curiosamente esta historia de la guerra
de la galaxia se parece mucho a la
historia de los hondureños y las
hondureñas
al igual que nuestro era de favorito
crecemos con nuestra mirada fijada en
las estrellas buscando algo más añorando
esa aventura galáctica desesperados por
irnos de casa
esta fue la historia que me contaron a
mí y no me la contó en george lucas ni
un escrito al gringo
la primera vez que escuché esta historia
fue de parte de un hondureño que me dijo
aquí no se puede
me dibujaron los límites rapidito y más
rapidito yo me conforme a ellos porque
si aquí no se podía tenía que buscar un
lugar donde si se podía entonces habría
aplique a una beca en el extranjero de
mountain él me da ni enfado que en
maleta en mano corazón en mano y le dije
adiós y nunca jamás a mi queridísima
honduras
y parece que esta historia bien común en
nuestros países latinoamericanos porque
solo en honduras la secretaría de
relaciones exteriores mantiene que un 90
por ciento de los hondureños prefieren
vivir allá
y por qué no yo también era parte de ese
90% estaba viviendo una vida feliz sin
dependiente luchando por buenas causas
como lo habían hecho tantos de mis
héroes favoritos en tantas de mis
historias favoritas me iba a graduar con
honores iba a conseguir un súper buen
trabajo en el exterior y porque no era
joven ingenua inteligentes tenía grandes
sueños y los límites parecían
desaparecer
bueno crisis me regresé
y cuando lo hice regresaba a un país que
parecía no tener final feliz regresé
desmotivada con cero ímpetu desganada
sentía que aquí terminaba mi aventura de
héroe
en la literatura existe una figura de
narrativa que se llama deus ex machina
el dios desde la máquina es cuando un
elemento externo a la narrativa se logra
meter y cambia definitivamente el
trayecto de nuestro héroe como si fuera
a caer del cielo naturalmente los
autores no les gusta esta figura
narrativa porque rara vez se asemeja a
la vida real las cosas no caen del cielo
vídeos ex machina fue vuelve al centro
un viernes lluvioso
recibí una llamada de un arquitecto y
así no contesto casi no contesto esta
llamada y no voy a contestar pero bueno
contestemos a lo y este arquitecto me
ofreció un trabajo y yo le dije está
bien y él me dijo que este cuento más el
lunes
entonces estoy en la oficina de nando mi
futuro jefe es un lunes por la mañana y
me está explicando la idea detrás de
vuelve al centro era una plataforma
digital que iba a promover tegucigalpa y
comayagüela los centros históricos de
nuestro país
y esto lo vamos a hacer con un blog y
redes sociales publicando artículos
fotografías vídeos para que la gente
volviera al centro
vamos a cambiar una ciudad así medio
nando
ok también es una ciudad no era
arquitecta no era funcionaria pública
había crecido con henri fires con más de
un macondo y un bachiller en literatura
pero voy a cambiar una ciudad ok
creo que lo que mi jefe había entendido
que tal vez yo no entendía un 7 o si al
para no necesitaba otro edificio
tegucigalpa no necesitaba a otro
funcionario público lo que tegucigalpa
necesitaba lo que honduras necesitaba
eran nueva historia
y si nosotros podríamos discernir los
elementos de una historia exitosa por
qué no aplicar esos mismos elementos a
la historia de una ciudad
no hay fórmula mágica para una buena
historia por eso es tan bella la
literatura todas son diferentes pero si
hay ciertas cosas que se repiten y que
logran que una narrativa sea exitosa y
la primera es con texto
no poder valorar lo que no conoces desde
un principio me explicaron esto yo no
conocía el centro histórico de
tegucigalpa como lo iba a escribir tenía
que ser mucha y mucha investigación
el galardón del premio nobel en
literatura de este año
y seguro
se enterró por cuatro semanas en su casa
para escribir para investigar y escribir
la novela los restos del día se cerró
del mundo real pero llamadas cero
correos la comida por debajo de las
puertas
yo no me encerré en mi casa pero sí fue
mucho trabajo porque para escribir
tegucigalpa tenía que entender su
contexto tenía que entender como este
pueblito minero había crecido
radicalmente con la llegada del
automóvil a principios del siglo 20 y
como cuando la ciudad creció sus
habitantes la abandonaron nos olvidamos
del centro histórico nos olvidamos del
corazón de la ciudad que también era el
corazón de la comunidad
y el látigo si al pan que yo me
encontraba ni con texto
era en un estado crítico
pero no siempre había sido así entonces
yo me esmeré en encontrar las historias
en buscar las historias de hace 20 30 40
años y lo primero que hice fue llamar a
mi mamá
ella me re dirigió mi abuela que me re
dirigió a un amigo historiador que me
sentó en su oficina por tres horas a
detallar me cada instante de su carrera
y así en cafés eternos en llamadas con
desconocidos
se fue solidificando esta idea de
tegucigalpa y ahora cuando caminaba por
las aceras del centro histórico y miraba
las fachadas arquitectónicas pensaba
hace medio siglo mi bisabuelo camino a
estas calles y tal vez llevaba a mi
abuelo de la mano y unos cuantos años
después tal vez mi abuelo llevó a mi
mamá de la mano aquí caminaba mi papá
aquí se paraba para esperar al bus
y tenían mi edad y pensaba tenían las
mismas preocupaciones que yo tenían las
mismas pasiones que yo como era su
aventura de héroe
pero el contexto no era suficiente las
fachadas arquitectónicas son bonitas
pero su cualidad es que son testigos de
una memoria de una ciudad y eso me trae
al segundo elemento de una historia
exitosa
sus personajes
desde un principio teníamos bien claro
que vuelva el centro era una plataforma
para empoderar las voces ciudadanas esa
historia de aquí no se puede nos hizo
callar
y nosotros teníamos que recuperar esas
voces
cómo se mira esto en la vida real en la
práctica se mira como te está caminando
por la peatonal acercándose a las
personas y diciéndole discúlpeme me
puede contar su historia para que la
pueda publicar en el blog
y las personas sigan corriendo
superrápidos lejos lejos de mí no lo es
si no tenían interés
tal vez estoy dramatizando un poquito
pero si era difícil no sé porque las
personas no querían contar las historias
y estaba desesperada y sudada en el
centro histórico ya no quería más
entonces me fui a quejar a un comedor
que se llamaba el buen gusto
y a medida que me quejaba con mi amiga
fotógrafa ya no puedo de no aguanto lo
mismo de siempre sentí una mano en la
espalda
y me di la vuelta
y esto es cuando conocí a soyapango
conozcan
suyapa llevaba más de 20 años visitando
ese mismo comedor donde me encontraba yo
era su segunda familia en el centro
histórico iba todos los días a comer y
suya promedio claro que yo le cuento mi
historia yo soy profesora y lo que más
quiero ver es como los niños salen
adelante en honduras
suyapa fue mi primera historia del
centro
para ese tiempo teníamos tal vez 10.000
20.000 seguidores en redes sociales y me
acuerdo que estaba en un museo y alguien
vino y se me acercó y dijo el que pinta
es la historia del centro ya ratos tengo
ganas de ir voy a volver y yo dije si la
gente está volviendo
era ingenua
y también más que contar la historia de
suyapa y contar historias
ajenas era empodera de empoderar a las
voces ciudadanas y que las personas
contaran sus propias historias que
escribieran artículos de cualquier tema
con tal que tuviera que ver con el
centro y nosotros lo íbamos a publicar y
qué emoción que tus palabras sean
publicadas
el único problema era que la mayoría de
las historias tenían 10 20 30 años de
edad
y esto me lleva al tercer elemento
indispensable de un buen cuento
la acción
nosotros teníamos la suerte que en
tegucigalpa en el centro histórico
estábamos viviendo una revolución
cultural existían personas accionando
desde hace 20 años en el centro mujeres
incursionando en las artes museos que
recuperaban la identidad y el espacio
público talleres de improvisación del
teatro grafiteros música alternativa un
violinista en la peatonal todo esto
estaba ahí y lo único que hacía falta
era de juntarlo promoverlo alzar la voz
dar a conocer
y así es como nació el festival devuelva
el centro la idea era juntar a todas
estas mentes maestras en un cuarto
ponerlos a platicar definir una
programación de 12 horas que las
familias se estacionarán desde temprano
y caminar en las calles como lo habían
hecho hace mucho tiempo y en la tarde
los jóvenes vendrían para la música
y qué bonito pensar que en cinco o diez
años alguien contaría la historia de
aquel sábado que bailamos en el parque
hoy nuestra modesta iniciativa cuenta
con casi 100.000 seguidores en las redes
sociales son 100.000 personas que siguen
y escriben nuestra historia
parece que el colorín colorado
pero este cuento no ha terminado
es una historia muy larga con muchos
personajes una narrativa de años y de
años y todos la escribimos
tal vez no se consideren escritores
entiendo el miedo que la pluma conlleva
plasmar tus ideas frente a las personas
frente a un auditorio con caras que te
están viendo si da miedo yo entiendo
pero les tengo noticias en este siglo 21
con un auge tecnológico y una
democratización de la palabra escrita
todos somos escritores
cada vez que publicas una fotografía
cada vez que comentas en el estatus de
tu amigo cada vez que le das me gusta a
una página estás escribiendo un
imaginario
y el imaginario colectivo el imaginario
de una comunidad se ve afectado por el
imaginario de sus integrantes
irónicamente es tu narrativa personal y
la manera en que decidís contarla día a
día afecta a la narrativa de tu ciudad
suena como una gran responsabilidad
porque lo es
y nuestras palabras importan
la manera en que decidimos contar
nuestras vidas importa los verbos que
usamos importan hace una semana exacta
un señor se me paró y me dijo están
destruyendo el parque finlay así me lo
dijo están destruyendo el parque
no estaban destruyendo el parque la
verdad era que estaban remodelando el
parque
porque sabía estudio porque yo había
visto el parque me había preocupado y
fui a indagar a la oficina y pregunté
qué está pasando y ellos me explicaron
el contexto del parque había sido
olvidado las personas ya no iban
remodele no lo conocía el contexto
conocía los personajes y que estaban
accionando
pero qué tal si este señor antes de
decirme esto a mí le tomó una foto al
parque y la publicó en sus redes
sociales y que atrás y puso están
destruyendo el parque bueno naturalmente
si bolt ven esta foto se la va a mandar
a tu mamá y se la va a mandar a su
abuela y se va a mandar a su amigo
historiador que va a escribir una
crónica larguísima denunciando la
destrucción del parque sí y antes que
nos demos cuenta hemos fabricado la
narrativa
falsa nuestras palabras importan
cambiemos nuestra ciudad
esta fue la historia que me contó mi
jefe y me gustó más
que la historia que había escuchado
mucho antes la historia de aquí no se
puede
la verdad es que yo no quiero ser un
personaje en la historia de alguien más
hay autores que han logrado visitar
ciudades que las han convertido en
historias que parecen sobrepasar la
realidad les doy el ejemplo de france de
nacho con new york o jorge si su querida
buenos aires
quien va a escribir san pedro sula
quien va a escribir mi tegucigalpa
quien escribe mi ciudad
es hora de empoderarnos de la pluma que
siempre pero siempre es más poderosa que
la espada investiguemos y conozcamos
nuestros contextos busquemos líderes y
campeones para nuestras causas y después
de todo eso acción hemos
tenemos que cambiar esta narrativa
latinoamericana tenemos que escribir
mejores ciudades gracias
[Aplausos]